hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be starting our coverage of the
2020
us chess championships being held this
year
wherever the contestants want to play it
is a remote event it is
online and so you're seeing competitors
play
in all different places some of them
playing in their own bedroom so it's
definitely interesting to see
that dynamic but we have 12 players
there will be 11 rounds playing
three games every day it's going to be
four days
i'm gonna be picking my favorite game
of each of the four days we're gonna
have four videos for the next
four days on the fourth day they do play
just two games instead of the three the
format's a little bit different it's 25
minutes per game with a five
second increment so five seconds added
after every single move
so not your normal classical style
chess where each players get a couple
hours for the entire game
so you're definitely going to see some
different openings you're going to see
some tactics that you may not see
in a longer style game because players
just don't have as long
to think in round number one that we're
going to be looking at
today we have white's going to be played
by jeffrey xiong
he is 19 years old he's the third
youngest player
in this tournament and his opponent
playing the black pieces
the youngest competitor and that is the
17 year old
a wonder liang so we'll go ahead and get
started
with jeffrey starting out with knight to
f3
knight f6 d4 g6
knight to d2 so not a common opening at
all and then after d5 we see b4
now if you are going to play this not
common opening
usually you see e3 as the main line here
uh jeffrey does go into the b4 and then
after
bishop to g7 if he encountering the
bishop here does now play
e3 so you can kind of interchange these
moves
you usually do end up with this setup
right here from white
castle on the king side bishop here to
e2
getting ready to castle on the king side
for white as well
upon here to c6 solidifying
this d5 pawn castle on the king side
and then a5 starting to chip away at
the queen side advance that jeffrey has
jeffrey pushes forward with b5 and then
a wonder plays
c5 had the option to go ahead and take
this pawn here
but then the bishop's gonna capture here
and then you could see
knight to c6 development move bishop
here to a3 putting a lot of pressure on
the king side with both of these bishops
barreling down here so
you know black decided didn't want to
have that position although i
i think it's completely fine instead
deciding to play the move here
on c5 we see a c3 here
just protecting the pawn here on d4 and
the knight to d7 as we start to look at
the position as far as where
white's gonna go has lots of different
variations could play bishop to a3 but
it does block off the pawn here on a2
and this bishop on a3 is not going to be
doing too much anytime
soon could just play a4 solidifying this
pawn here on
uh b5 and now if the bishop wants to
come here to a3 could definitely do that
there's no real good move for any of the
knights
uh clearly not gonna be bringing the
knight just to h4 for no reason
uh e5 and g5 don't make a ton of sense
if you bring your knight over here to b3
it is leaving this e4 square
open so you could just see knight two e4
it's kind of a pain that white
is going to have to deal with you could
get your queen involved into the game
queen to c2 makes some sense if you want
to try that you could see
h3 you could see rook 2e1 so a lot of
moves that white has none of them
really putting much pressure on black
you can see both sides playing
fairly passive uh this opening is
you know very i would say drawlish for
both sides uh not a lot
of crazy tactical lines you're putting
on your opponent in a 25 minutes game
here
but we do see white continue with a4
and black responds with b6
now the dark square bishop does come to
a3 wanted to go ahead and push this pawn
up here to a4
to protect the palm before the bishop
comes to
this a3 square now bishop to b7
just getting the rest of the pieces
involved into the action uh c4 could
have played c4 earlier when he did play
c3 but now decides to go ahead and
attack in the center of the board you
get a sense that things are building up
on this c file here
with the bishop this knight here this
bishop here on a3 all attacking
these uh c pawns this knight here on
d7 as well as this rook here on c8
everything lining up here on
the c file so white continues with the
same theme here
rook to c1 rook to e8 here and then we
start to see some
pieces exchange in the board so the pawn
here on c4
takes on d5 we see the knight take pawn
takes here on c5
we see a bunch of exchanges going on in
the center of the board
and then queen to b3 if you look at this
position right here
black does have the bishop pair so that
is a good thing
that black has going for him but if you
look from white's perspective
both sides equal in material but black
now has two isolated pawns that white's
going to be able to attack for the rest
of the game
white has these two pawns that are
connected and so that's going to be much
easier for white to hold on to than
black standpoint so
while usually you want to have the
bishop pair and you're just playing
offense
black is going to have to get pretty
creative to hold on to both of his pawns
or else is going to go down quite a bit
immaterial
now one of the threats that wonder has
here is playing knight to
c3 attacking the queen it's defended by
the bishop here on
g7 so uh jeffrey plays queen to
b3 getting his queen involved into the
game is the last piece that he needed to
develop here
and so that defends uh the square here
on
uh c3 definitely don't see black giving
up a knight
and a bishop here for a rook and so we
see the knight come back here to b6
attacking the pawn here on uh a4
but also is just under attack by the
queen so once you just come back also
opens up for the queen here on
d8 for this open file to start to attack
rook here to d1 after the knight moves
then
white recognizing that he has a
discovered attack on the queen
once this knight moves so that's exactly
what he does queen to c7 recognizing the
threat so wants to get the queen
off of this open file once the knight
moves and that's exactly where the
knight moves
here to c4 and this is doing a couple
thing it's attacking not only this
knight here on
b6 but it's also attacking this pawn
here
on a5 which is one of the isolated pawns
that we talked about which is a huge
weakness for
black now one of the ways to
attack a piece that is threatening one
of your
pieces of material is to just pin that
material down and that's exactly what we
see black do bishop here to
d5 pinning down the knight we see that i
come here to d2 wasn't doing too much
here on the f3 square so knight to
d2 defending this knight here on
c4 rook over here to d8 queen back to
c2 does want to get out of
the pin here and then pawn to e6 now if
we look at it you can clearly see
that the knight can take here on a5
but it's also difficult to see you know
how black really holds on to it if he
plays rook to
a8 okay well this rook
was also defending this c file so if we
start to exchange here then i can take
on
b6 and after the queen takes now the
queen can take here on
c5 and white is up material so yes the
rook move over here to protect the pawn
on a5
but then black still goes down in
material and this is not a good setup
for black so if we come back black
decides okay i'm going to go ahead and
give up
that pawn in material here and so we see
pawn two e6 solidifying this bishop here
on d5 as an outpost and the knight takes
here on a5 remember
in the shorter matches 25 minutes
with five second increments it's not
terrible to go down upon the material
now you definitely don't want to do that
but it's not the end of the world
and so you'll typically see these
players playing games out where
if you know your opponent had an hour
two hours to think through it
not going to make many mistakes at the
highest level many times you would see a
resignation
early on but black has many many chances
to come back
and win this game for sure now we see
the rook 2a8
attacking the knights knight comes up
here to uh c4
defending the knights here on a5 we do
see the bishop take
then i come back here to c4 capture
and then the knight takes here on a4 so
black
does get a pawn back in material
but after bishop to f3 and this is a
critical square here attacking
the rook the rook takes here on d1
rook recaptures here now rook to a7
this is the critical square that jeffrey
was looking for and that is
rook to d6
as you hear jeffrey talk about the game
he calculated this move
many moves before and that just lets you
know just how extraordinary this 19 year
old is
in these shorter games that he can
calculate this specific position because
the real threat
that he has here is let's say that black
played king to f8 which would be a
terrible move but just to show you
exactly what white has
and that is pawn to b6 the knights
and the rook are both defending this
pawn right here you can see the pond's
forking both the queen and the rook
there so after the knight takes
the rook comes to b6 and it's protected
white just goes up more and more
material here but
some of the challenge that black has is
where does
he defend so the rook can't go anywhere
if it comes to a8
or b7 both of those squares are defended
by the bishop here on
f3 it can't come to a6 that's being
attacked by this
pawn on b5 and it can't come to a5
that's under attack from
the knights we already know that the
pawn coming up here to b6 is going to
attack
this rook right here on a7 if the queen
moves
elsewhere well it doesn't have too many
good squares maybe comes to b8 because
it still wants to put pressure on
this b pawn but
now the pawn can still push forward with
b6
now rook to a6 was the only square
left that's no longer being under attack
because the pawn did move here
but then now queen to d1
and how does black really stop this here
you can see the pawn pushing up here you
can see
the rook right here is now threatening
rook 2d8
check and this is also attacking the
queen here
but the rook is protected by the queen
here on
d1 this knight can't really do too much
this pawn is protected by multiple
pieces here
all these light squares are being
attacked by the bishop here so you can
see things are not going well
uh for black and so uh decides to try
something
tricky uh definitely if you kind of run
this through a simulation
definitely not the best move but i think
black really had to try
something because everything else i
think
white had calculated exactly how black
would play
but don't think he was expecting that to
c3 just because i don't think this was
the strongest move
in the in the game uh but after knight
two c3
uh i said okay yeah if you're not going
to stop my forward here i'm gonna go
ahead and play pawn
to b6
now black played the move rook to a1
anytime you
are in a fork or under attack if you can
move that piece away and attack your
opponent's king that is
one option to do and so now we see the
interesting move of rook
to d1 realizing that
after the knight takes here and you
could also take with your rook that's
one option but then just the queen takes
and after the queen takes up here uh
then knight takes knight takes
bishop takes and you can see white is
clearly up in material
uh getting into the in game this would
be a pretty easy a minor piece versus a
pawn
uh with no real way for black to come
back from this so
decides not to do that instead decides
to take with his knight here on d1
and white decides to go ahead and take
with his pawn here on
c7 so says yeah i don't i don't really
care that this is
you're taking material down here you
also have a discovered attack which is
exactly
what uh black plays uh so this is
check here but then the bishop to d1 a
very nice way to defend this
because after the knight takes here on
c2
then pawn promotes to c8 and it is
check so bishop to f8 stopping that
queen to d8 this is still putting the
pressure the
bishop is still pinned down to the king
but now it's defending this bishop here
on d1
you can start to see that black is
running out of options here king 2
g7 pawn up here 2h4
knight to d4 recognizing does need to
centralize this knight a little bit here
knight to e3 knight to f5 and then
h5 and this is a really really strong
move now in the game black
played knight takes on e3 which is the
correct move but it's very tempting to
just take this pawn here on h4
but this would be a huge mistake because
of
not the move g4 which i did analyze as
well but the move knight takes
on f5 check now after the pawn takes
then queen to g5
can't move to any of these squares the
only legal move here is 2 h8
and then queen 2 f 6
check now the bishop can't just come to
g7
because that's going to be checkmate
queen 2 d8 check
bishop 2f8 and then that's going to be
checkmate so we are
already can see the bishop can't come
here the only other option is king 2
g8 and then you can see that we have
forked the rook here on
a one so that would have been pretty
fantastic
uh if black was not able to see that but
correctly did see it and played knight
takes here on
e3 and then pawn takes here for you know
from white's perspective
jeffrey just wants all the pieces to
come off the board he's up in material
clearly
with the queen on board so if he can
trade off that is a
win for him
now we see the rook come back here to a6
bishop to b3 rook over here to
d6 trying to block off the queen uh
while also
attacking it so the rook is defended by
the bishop here so trying to coordinate
these pieces it's very difficult to do
that with a queen that can maneuver all
over the board queen here two g5
rook to d7 queen to e5 also
black at this point is running out of
time jeffrey
has quite a bit of time uh but wonder
does not have much time left on his
clock at this point just so
everyone has an idea of what's going on
here
bishop to c4 rook down to d1 check
king 2 f2 many times you'll see the king
come over here to
h2 but since black does not have a queen
on the board you can start to get your
king involved
into the attack here rook 2 c1
attacking the bishop queen comes back
here to f4
uh not only is there a discovered attack
if the pawn moves but this is also
defending this bishop here on c4 king 2
g7 pawn to g4 starting to push up the
pawns to add pressure
here bishop to e7 queen to
e5 check king g8 queen up here to
b8 and then king 2 g7 this is the
decisive move
really needed to play bishop here to f8
but in the game we have king 2 g7
and then for those people that really
like puzzles this is kind of a one move
to win the game not necessarily
checkmate but to win the game and
gets the resignation and that is queen
to b2
it's a fork attacking the king here and
the rook here
on c1 and in this spot black
did resign
so congratulations to jeffrey on a very
well deserved
victory i was looking back at last year
and actually did first round and
jeffrey was in that game as well so i
guess first round i just like to uh
watch him play i think he does extremely
well hoping that he has
a very good tournament so hopefully you
guys are excited about this tournament
one of my favorites
all year that i always put on the
counter want to make sure that we do
coverage for it
so we'll have a video for the next four
days but thank you guys so much for
watching the video
thanks so much for supporting the
channel and i'll see y'all tomorrow
for a game from either round four round
five or
round six we'll just have to wait and
see what i come up with
thanks guys bye